The answer is a straight line, and the reason is really subtle.
It's because we're not modifying the first and last point.
Otherwise, it would be a single point.
I just hit the run button, and if you look at these coordinates, they go in 0.5 increments
from 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, and the same is true with this coordinate over here.
This is obviously the coordinates of a straight line
as a result of our smoother applied with a smoothing weight of 0.1 and no data weight.
If we change this to no smoothing weight, we obviously get the original path.
If we look at the right side as well as the left side, it's not identical.
When you implement your algorithm, please test this on those settings,
and we will give you a different path in our testing to see if your algorithm is implemented correctly.
Congratulations!
You just learned how to produce a smooth path. There are a few caveats.
If you apply this algorithm in a robot world like this where an A-star planner might give you something like this,
the smooth path might then lead straight through the obstacle, which you don't want.
There are ways to accommodate this, which I'll just hint at.
One is to use dynamic programming with a stochastic action function.
You've learned this in the previous homework assignment.
That way we stay away from the obstacle.
The second one is to introduce a term that propels you away from obstacles.
I won't go into any depth here, but in your optimization you could have a term
that pushes you away from obstacles
by maximizing the distance between the nearest obstacle and data point.
When you toss that in, you get a path that might look more like this
that is still smooth but maximizes your clearance from obstacles.
We will revisit this in the homework assignment.